Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Foreign
We are picking up where we left off in
the book of purification, the chapter of
U
and the subchapter regarding
the occasions, the times, the instances
in which it is preferred that a person
make wudoo. We mentioned before in order
to do three things or a person must make
wudoo
for three things
for salah for
for handling the mus. But then there are
many other things in which it is
preferred that a person have woo for and
thus far the author has mentioned five
of these things or we've gone through
five of these things in detail.
However, he mentions nine altogether.
The sixth
instance in which it is preferred
that a person make
the author says
that it is preferred encouraged highly
encouraged that a person make for each
salah. And this actually used to be
obligatory at the beginning
and the early stages of
revelation
or when the verse was revealed. The
sixth verse of surah
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
for
[Silence]
So Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says in the
verse of wudoo,
if you wish to pray then make wudoo.
This clearly articulates that it is
obligatory and so it was it was
obligatory.
But then later in the conquest of Mecca,
some scholars cite the conquest of Mecca
as being the time when the ruling of
obligation was abregated.
It was abregated and it was relieved
from being obligatory to being
preferred.
Being preferred.
Why does this happen? Why does it happen
that something would be obligatory at
first and then later made
only preferred and not and no longer
obligatory.
This is
there is a lot of wisdom in the
obligations that Allah subhanahu wa tala
has set and then later relieved to
preferred things
and that is that he is he is teaching
and cultivating an entire generation
most of them older men right especially
in the early days of Islam
is were the big adults and the older men
and so forth that were really embracing
Islam,
right? And the younger men were entering
into Islam. And so to teach that
discipline
and in order to arrive at the place
where Allah wanted to see them, he
commanded them with that which was
more intense than what he initially
desired ultimately. So he commands them
with that which is obligatory and then
once they take to the obligation he
later he later reduces it to something
that is preferred
right and this is to teach discipline
and to build good habits. If a person
wants to start a new habit they have to
treat that habit as if it is obligatory.
It is obligatory until the habit sets
and takes and then after that the person
can you know
can fall short of the habit when
necessary.
But making wudoo for each salah was
originally
that is the way that it was originally
set is that you wanted to make salah.
You begin with making wudoo
and then you stand for salah.
later that was reduced to.
You don't have to make woo as long as
you haven't broken your woo. But it is
highly preferred, highly encouraged that
you make woo for each salah.
[Silence]
We will do inch.
Wasam.
foral.
[Silence]
I'm done.
And so
he tells us that the prophet sallallam's
action and his habit was that he would
always make wudoo for each salah always.
He would always make woo for each salah.
And so on the day of the conquest of
Mecca, the prophet sallall.aii Wasam
made and he wiped over his leather
his leather footwear
and then he made all of the prayers of
that day in with the same wuboo with the
same wuboo.
And so Alma said to him, "Oh messenger
of Allah, you did something today that
you've never I've never seen you do that
you did not practice before."
Commenting about his praying all the
prayers with one and the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam said, "I did that
on purpose." Meaning I did it purposely.
I did it very deliberately to articulate
what Om just learned and that is that
the obligation has been relaxed to
the status of highly encouraged.
Highly encouraged. So what do we
understand from this?
We understand from this that if we were
to really look at the sunnah,
we would we could probably put a
percentage on it and we could say
95 maybe even 97 or 98% of the time he
would make for each even in travel. Now
notice that Omar is saying I've never
seen you do this before. Even in travel,
he's never seen him do this before,
right? And in travel, if there's any
time when a person would have the need
to make more than one salah with each
wool would be during travel at that
time. Water is limited, right? However,
he would always make wudoo for each
salah.
Meaning that that's really the way it is
supposed to be. However, very
very
seldomly was he narrated to have made
wudoo
made multiple prayers on the same
wudoo. So this articulates that the
overwhelming
amount of
narrations that articulate his sunnah
would be that he would make wudoo for
each salah and sometimes he would make
multiple salas on one wudoo but that was
the exception to the rule. Usually he
would time for salah. There is a ritual
for salah. And why is that? Why why make
wudoo for each salah when we already
have wudoo? Well, it's not just about
the
state of being which is a state of
spiritual purity. When a person has
wudoo, that's not the only reason and
benefit of making wudoo.
One of the
points of making wuboo is that it
expedates sins
that have been committed with the body
parts, the eyes, the face. The prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam tells us
that when a person makes woo and washes
his face the sins that he observed with
his eyes
all are expedated with the lap last
drips of water that drip from his face
and likewise his hands and likewise his
feet etc. Another reason is to prepare
oneself for salah.
Because if a person has no
has no
practice or no prerequisite to salah,
they go from whatever it is that they're
doing and then suddenly go into making
salah.
That contrast
very rarely is a person's mind just like
a switch
that you can be dealing with work or
dealing with whatever it is and then
just by saying Allahbar immediately you
just switch off that thing that you were
doing and now you are all in on salah.
That's very very rare that a person has
the discipline to do that. Most of the
time
when a person makes and starts to
pray the first
or first half they're still on the gear
of whatever it is that they were doing
before they started praying. And so if
you jump straight into salah, you will
lose that first amount of prayer because
how much of your salah do you actually
keep and are you actually rewarded for?
How much of it? How much of it?
Whatever you whatever you're there for,
whatever you're present for, you only
get of your salah what you comprehended.
The rest you lost. And this is why the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam said a
person may make salah.
Some people will make salah and they
have all of the salah. Some only walk
away with 9/10. Some only walk away with
8/10. Some only walk away with 7/10.
Right? And he continued sixth and five
and four and three and two and some
people walk away with not nothing of
their salah because the whole salah they
were elsewhere. That's all you get from
your prayer. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
is only going to give you of his
attention what you give him as of yours.
He's not going to give you full
attention while you give him none or
partial attention. And so you notice
that there is a buffer, a cushion
between the actual obligation of salah
and the preparations for salah,
right?
We look at the preparations. The
preparations are you you make you make
after the you listen to the you say what
the says and then you're encouraged to
brush your teeth and then you're
encouraged to make woo and then you're
encouraged to make this after woo and
then you're encouraged to make for and
then you're encouraged to make the
sunnah for the salah and sunnah for
entering the masid. All of this is to
buffer and to get your mind into the
salah so that when the prayer actually
begins, you're present for it from the
beginning. That's the idea. And so this
is another buffer for that also to
expedate one's sins before he enters
into salah. There's many many many
benefits of making mudoo for each
[Arabic recitation]